medic
oh Jesus
Beth we should go
millions of dollars worth of cocaine
fell from the sky this morning in
Knoxville Tennessee there's more this
out there they dumped it somewhere I'm
looking for my daughter's first is a
dangerous place hey Henry check it out
something got into it a deer Maybe
a lot of cocaine was lost I need you to
go and get it
no no don't eat that don't eat that
let's see what kind of effect that has
[Music]
the bear it [__] did cocaine
you're getting cocaine
there was a bear a bear it was far hey
that's inappropriate
you're safe Bears can't climb trees of
course they can
oh [__]
[Music]
it kind of seems like the thing that
stays with the man forever
apex predator
high on cocaine
out of his mind
oh man you [__] what the [__] is wrong
with that man
[Music]
we have such good luck in nature
what